i'm in the middle of a documentary you
did on your sister
your sister no no [ __ ] was really
the queen of men this is a woman who was
running a huge
drug operation like in breaking bad i
mean she was over four states
it's pretty mind-blowing that your
sister put this whole thing
together where she became a meth dealer
and you know it kind of
what i like about it is you understand
how she ended up in this fix
because the parenting was just so bad
they had absolutely no guidance in life
you know we my sister's a year younger
we grew up our father
raised us by himself and and then when i
was 10 he married the next door neighbor
and i ended up when i was 15 moving in
with our mom
our mom was a lunatic i do that like
she's married seven times she's an
alcoholic
yeah your mom she's the last person on
earth you'd want her
to be your mom she was not motherly at
all she was not protective at all you
know my sister was closer because my
sister
followed me over to bob's house bob was
with her seven
six six uh husband and like i just want
to go there to drink
and have no rules and grow my hair
because there's no [ __ ] rules there
so [ __ ] that she comes my sister
worshipped our mom
and my my dad's big mistake was he never
badmouthed our mom
everybody's like oh that's the way to be
but when she would come over like crazy
and
knock the christmas tree down and just
be it where very inappropriate he never
actually
had kids what you just thought it's what
i do with my kids if their mom does some
that was not appropriate i would never
treat her that way
i would never let you guys treat anyone
that way
and and then we move on it doesn't have
to be i'm gonna beat up this uh
you know and my dad did so my sister's
sense of reality
was so stilted that she thought my mom's
a hero and so she was in that world that
there's drugs
and then at a certain point she said i'm
going to turn this into i'm going to be
the best
there ever was at this because she was
smart and built this
empire yeah you got to see this
documentary thomas and queen of meth
and it's now airing on discovery plus
and it really is an
unbelievable story tom's even thinking
of turning the documentary into a
scripted series
and you've even said you'd like margot
robbie to play your sister and it would
be a great
role for her because she could do that
move where you playing yourself up you
don't wear any makeup then she could get
the academy award right
yeah and i said i said that it's in the
to page six or whatever
and then my sister's like i said you
know like monster charlize thrown
in monster i said it and then my sister
calls me what the [ __ ]
i thought do i look like that and i was
like well you know that's kind of stuff
you say to get projects going